hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
who and I'm John we are going to watch a
compilation video or something like that
cool Game of Thrones Jamie Lannister
Oathbreaker Jaime Lannister one of our
war tears for a certain pledge is
whatever video you request we must
definitely do Austin Harris we just got
done doing a Google hangout with
requested Game of Thrones Jamie
Lannister Oathbreaker so let's let's do
this no this dick about this dick
someone forgot to write down on your
birdies is that 4:40 rhodonite with one
hand
no not every vow you ever took so many
vows you swear as well
Father protect innocent defend the weak
what if your father despises the king
mice
[Music]
damn he is one of the best characters on
this show man
devastated build of the Seven Kingdoms
protector of the realm
Kings say
[Music]
[Music]
I remember that moment
this show flashback of him killing the
king
I've seen every episode once so I don't
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's a good guy
for the same I was so honored you
[Music]
that's right
I feel like I'm an Oathbreaker
are you yeah I'm not loyal at all to
anymore or anything I tried to tell one
reliable guy I'll manipulate every
situation yes oh yeah according to plan
now I care about me look out for me
that's not Jamie that's the thing with
Jamie he breaks posts because he cares
about people I think Jamie has arguably
the most compelling character art and we
talked about this with Austin Harris we
did because even just seeing the footage
here hey let's start with the physical
first season long hair clean as a
whistle then he starts getting some
facial hair gets his arm chopped off and
then now he's got this nice haircut and
just a little bit of facial hair you
know it's just nice him yeah I just
imagine Jamie with just anyway that was
Jamie's physical appearance but in the
first season and the second season he
just seems like huge day he's such an
[ __ ]
I hate the guy yeah and then the third
season that's when bran of Tarth gets
introduced and then you start to pull
back layers he loses his hand he becomes
more vulnerable and you start learning
the history of why he killed the king
and all these things just start coming
out is rotation like wow this guy
actually cares okay I started to see
what people liked about him even the way
season 7 ends with his character with
him running away from Cersei it looks
like he's running to help out Daenerys
and stuff yeah I mean he's had a really
moral or two over time if he has a heart
is he loves he loves the Lannisters
that's his family but he knows they're
[ __ ] up yeah well in this video kind
of reminded me of all the suffering I
forgot how much time he spent in mud and
dirt and chained up and kept in a box
and stuff like that he was sitting in
his own poop for a long time yeah I'll
never forget that learning that fact
like oh yeah they just made prisoners
send in their own feces
they took Jamie to the bottom yeah he
came out with at least a better sense of
what's right and empathy the one woman
he loves seems like impossible to trust
and cheats on him it's tough dude it's
tough being Jamie he just loves the
Lannisters he loves his family he loves
his people but he also sees that he
might be fighting on the wrong side
because Jamie's kind of like the
in-between of Tyrion and Cersei in a lot
of ways he has a lot of the qualities of
both just combined into one he's
ruthless because he's been trained to be
but then over time he's becoming less
ruthless but when he has to still fight
and do something for the kill his
[ __ ] dragon for killing people well
yeah he seems to at least have shared
some of Tyrians intellect like I'm never
rule Astrid's like everything has to
advance yeah for him please and it all
stems from a place of loving Cersei
oh there's yes Cersei was my sister I'm
not gonna even make that whoa hey Austin
Harris thanks for requesting this dude
we got to get to know you today
this guy's super into politics did not
vote for Trump which I was really upset
by because I haven't met enough Trump oh
you're about because my algorithm all my
social media and my search results
always tends to people who don't hide in
a bubble and Austin Harris this guy's
from Indiana and right now I could just
feel a sincere soul in this guy he's
quiet but he occasionally says some
really funny stuff he's a funny guy he's
got a plain bedroom and honestly I
wouldn't be surprised if he was like one
of those serial killers that I liked oh
who you would like later see on an
episode of mine hunter yeah I would have
liked to have interviewed this guy maybe
that and this guy told us that he used
to work at Burger King and they actually
grill their food bro in fact royal
that's what he said quoting you Austin
Austin I'm sorry if I made some jokes
that made you uncomfortable it's just
what I do but if I can give you one
piece of advice you told us you're the
youngest if your sisters anything like
Cersei
that [ __ ] how you just party the patreon
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up you look you look like
Jesus not not Jesus Christ
ha ha you look like Jesus from The
Walking Dead interesting what's that
character like well he heals people and
he doesn't walk on water yeah it's the
first time they didn't really introduce
his hardcore supernatural element to the
wide oh yeah well they supposed to be
like an act no he just looks like Jesus
and check out our patreon while you're
at it
peace